yeah i mean
i mean gifted a curse right you're going
to jail almost added to like the allure
of of your of you as an artist
yeah pretty much kind of like when boozy
got out he was you know what i was
saying like
it just added to yeah like you know what
i'm saying like and i think also
your the circumstances of your case yeah
that too were very
it felt like some [ __ ] yeah so even
people who necessarily weren't tapped in
with their music when they found out
about what was going on they were like
yo this is crazy like people are just
rooting for you you know what i'm saying
yeah
there's a lot of people who wasn't a lot
of people who wasn't rooting for me
who wasn't rooting for you i'm not
saying to say names but like who like
uh the older dudes the people that have
been in the game for a minute
um la rappers yep that's fair
i could see that yeah yo um
did what what do you think because it
was this judge
that was really she had like a vendetta
for you right she was because she did
not like me
at all i don't know what it was like
maybe because i was a rapper because she
told me that in korea i don't know if
you think because you're a rapper like
you don't gotta listen to the rules i'm
like
you could have just said this for the
gym don't make it seem like you don't
like me bro like
it's almost like they're sending an
example or some [ __ ] pretty much that's
exactly what it was i mean i was
yesterday was trying it didn't work
though so then she got bounced right
in the election is that what happened
that's the d.a yeah yeah
she got or the the it was the dna was
indiana judge
the d.a and the judge but once the
election happened yeah she got kicked
the book
it almost happened like simultaneously
it was like the election happened and it
was like oh he's coming home
pretty much yeah all of a sudden that's
they had a deal all of a sudden
you can go home right now i'm like after
all this like
y'all could have been let me go all
right